u.s. marshal this morning at
approximately 8 40 buildings was shot on
by an active shooter law enforcement
responded immediately and I want to
assure the community especially our
downtown community that the community is
safe and I'm gonna let FBI special agent
charge to Sarno give you additional
details as you know we won't be going
getting any questions today but we will
have a more detailed press conference
later on this afternoon where we'll take
questions it's in charge of FBI Dallas
shortly after the incident began this
morning officers from the Federal
Protective Service engaged shooter who
was later identified as Brian Isaac and
Clyde
you must take it to Baylor Hospital and
pronounced deceased on scene at this
time we have no information indicating
that there are other shooters other
threats to the community we are working
on one vehicle and we will we will have
that clear shortly the investigation
will continue with the aid and
assistance of my partners who stand here
with me the ATF the Federal Protective
Service the u.s. marshals and the Dallas
Police Department if anyone in the
public has information that could be of
assistance either regarding the subject
or the incident please call 1-800 call
FBI and you can submit video and
photographs to tips fbi.gov we will
provide another name is spelled last
name dispelled I
a Brian Isaac Clyde P Rin is a AC K CL y
de age 22